Let's do a few more examples of
finding the limit of functions
as x approaches infinity
or negative infinity.
So here I have this
crazy function.
9x to the seventh
minus 17x to the sixth,
plus 15 square roots of x.
All of that over 3x to
the seventh plus 1,000x
to the fifth, minus
log base 2 of x.
So what's going to happen
as x approaches infinity?
And the key here, like we've
seen in other examples,
is just to realize which
terms will dominate.
So for example,
in the numerator,
out of these three terms,
the 9x to the seventh
is going to grow much faster
than any of these other terms.
So this is the dominating
term in the numerator.
And in the denominator,
3x to the seventh
is going to grow much faster
than an x to the fifth term,
and definitely much faster
than a log base 2 term.
So at infinity, as we get
closer and closer to infinity,
this function is going
to be roughly equal to 9x
to the seventh over
3x to the seventh.
And so we can say,
especially since,
as we get larger and larger
as we get closer and closer
to infinity, these
two things are
going to get closer
and closer each other.
We could say this
limit is going to be
the same thing as this limit.
Which is going to be
equal to the limit
as x approaches infinity.
Well, we can just cancel
out the x to the seventh.
So it's going to
be 9/3, or just 3.
Which is just going to be 3.
So that is our limit, as
x approaches infinity,
in all of this craziness.
Now let's do the same with
this function over here.
Once again, crazy function.
We're going to
negative infinity.
But the same principles apply.
Which terms dominate as
the absolute value of x
get larger and
larger and larger?
As x gets larger in magnitude.
Well, in the numerator, it's
the 3x to the third term.
In the denominator it's
the 6x to the fourth term.
So this is going to be the
same thing as the limit of 3x
to the third over 6x to
the fourth, as x approaches
negative infinity.
And if we simplified
this, this is
going to be equal to the
limit as x approaches
negative infinity of 1 over 2x.
And what's this going to be?
Well, if the denominator,
even though it's
becoming a larger and larger
and larger negative number,
it becomes 1 over a very,
very large negative number.
Which is going to get us
pretty darn close to 0.
Just as 1 over x, as x
approaches negative infinity,
gets us close to 0.
So this right over here,
the horizontal asymptote
in this case, is
y is equal to 0.
And I encourage you to graph
it, or try it out with numbers
to verify that for yourself.
The key realization here
is to simplify the problem
by just thinking
about which terms
are going to dominate the rest.
Now let's think about this one.
What is the limit of
this crazy function
as x approaches infinity?
Well, once again, what
are the dominating terms?
In the numerator, it's 4x to the
fourth, and in the denominator
it's 250x to the third.
These are the
highest degree terms.
So this is going to be the
same thing as the limit,
as x approaches infinity, of
4x to the fourth over 250x
to the third.
Which is going to be the same
thing as the limit of-- let's
see, 4, well I
could just-- this is
going to be the same thing
as-- well we could divide two hundred
and, well, I'll just
leave it like this.
It's going to be the
limit of 4 over 250.
x to the fourth divided by
x to the third is just x.
Times x, as x
approaches infinity.
Or we could even say this
is going to be 4/250 times
the limit, as x
approaches infinity of x.
Now what's this?
What's the limit of x as
x approaches infinity?
Well, it's just going
to keep growing forever.
So this is just going to
be, this right over here
is just going to be infinity.
Infinity times some
number right over here
is going to be infinity.
So the limit as x approaches
infinity of all of this,
it's actually unbounded.
It's infinity.
And a kind of obvious way
of seeing that, right,
from the get go, is to
realize that the numerator has
a fourth degree term.
While the highest degree
term in the denominator
is only a third degree term.
So the numerator is
going to grow far faster
than the denominator.
So if the numerator
is growing far faster
than the denominator,
you're going
to approach infinity
in this case.
If the numerator is growing
slower than the denominator,
if the denominator is growing
far faster than the numerator,
like this case, you
are then approaching 0.
So hopefully you find
that a little bit useful.